now and onto our story President Biden
admitting that critics who say he's too
old for the presidency may be right the
president revealing to democratic donors
that he would have skipped a reelection
bid if he were not facing Donald Trump
Joe telling them this during a
fundraiser if Trump wasn't running I'm
not sure I'd be running but we cannot
let him win for the sake of the country
Biden then had to walk back his comments
and insisted that he would be running no
matter what would you be running for
president Trump wasn't running I I
expect so but look he is running and I
just I have to run you drop
out no not now do you think there is any
Democrat who could defeat Donald Trump
other than you probably 50 of them you
do believe that there I'm not the only
one de him but I will defeat him who
else do you think could defeat Donald
Trump Mr President but former president
Donald Trump thinks Joe Biden won't even
be his opponent in the 20 24 race I
personally don't think he makes it I
think he's in bad shape physically do
you remember when he said I'd like to
take him behind the barn if he took me
behind the barn and I went like
this I believe he'd fall over I see
Biden talking about oh mega magga mega
means make America great again that's
what it means and that's what people
want Jesse usually in a closed door
fundraiser you say what you mean and so
this came out of the fundraiser and then
he had to try to walk it back but pretty
much he's admitting that President Trump
is the lifeline of his candidacy
fundraiser Biden's my favorite Biden
that's a good Biden that's a good Biden
but he's telling the truth and he never
tells the truth so he's saying he's the
only one who can beat Trump and that's
why he's
running but then what Dana so he's going
to run win and then give K of the keys
to the White House he's not running for
a second term he's just running as a
grudge match and then it's here kamla
you're next what about us what about the
voters it should be about the voters it
shouldn't be about your personal
obsession with your opponent he hasn't
laid out a vision for the second term he
hasn't laid out an agenda for the second
term I don't like that and I believe now
every time Trump says this that he's not
going to make it I'm starting to agree
because today when he was
asked why are you hanging out with your
brother and your son's Associates and he
said that's a
lie now this isn't Donald Trump saying I
had a big crowd on inauguration day or I
thought the hurricane was going to hit
this state this is like going out in
front of the American people and the
American Press Corps and saying the sky
is green and then just walking away we
have photos
of him at dinners with the
associates we have logs to the White
House of the vice president's residents
I've been meeting dozens of his son and
brother's
Associates we have his own lawyers
explaining why he was on the phone to
his son's Associates because we just
talk about the weather so if
everything's kosher and I am I saying
that correctly if everything kosher
Jessica why is he blatantly lying about
that and can he do that for a whole year
you could talk about that Jessica if you
want or I could ask you the question I
just had here which was this will add
another log to the fire of people who
think he won't be the nominee and that
he doesn't really want the job and that
he's preventing this Civil War from
breaking out in the Democratic party
which might need to happen for there to
be a next Generation so I'll start with
the Jew question yes that was the proper
use of the term
kosher um so a couple of things uh I
also enjoy fundraiser Biden and frankly
think he should have stuck with it
because that was the argument that he
made in 2020 and it persuaded 81 million
people that he was the right person for
that job and we've seen in terms of
turnout and everything else from the
midterms to all these referendums that
Donald Trump juices his base but he
really juices Democrats and they show up
to vote against him and Joe Biden has
done incredibly well in the Trump year
not only winning his own election but
his party has overperformed expectations
time and time again and a lot of that
has to do with the me versus Trump of
all of this and I don't think he should
have walked it back frankly and then
gone on to say oh 50 other Dems could
have done it we all know that's not true
I'm sure there are a couple other
Democrats that could have done it but
it's about you it's about the agenda
that you set forward and building on
your progress finish the job
um to your point about all these things
that the Republicans have Joe Biden
doing the pictures and the blah blah
blah you really need to take James
Comer's job because he's terrible at it
every interview that he does whether
it's on our Network or this morning he
showed up on NBC and props to him for
going into enemy territory or whatever
he got absolutely destroyed the big
revelation of the week was the under
$4,000 truck loan um which has been it's
an old story that the post had to begin
with that came out in 2022 um he it was
this all occurred in 2018 when he was in
an office
Etc the investigations are going nowhere
I know it's frustrating to you and to
Fang Fang or whatever you're going to
say and the Diamonds that are all over
the place um comr very bad at your job
wait a where's the evidence it was alone
what it was set out the the post itself
our our own New York Post what the
evidence the payback on it and there was
no interest because it was his son that
Hunter paid his dad back for the where
was the loan initially from Joe Hunter
what that's what a loan is Jessica you
loan someone money and they pay you back
we're getting a little bog down no we
are well Jesse is I I wasn't bogged at
all I was actually floating great um the
ju position of last night so Biden is at
the fundraiser and Donald Trump is doing
his town hall with Shan Hannity and
Shawn was doing his best to help him out
asking questions like hey Bud um are you
planning on being a dictator and then he
floats around he does a bunch of things
he says he's innocent all these
indictments he's treated worse than Al
Capone blah blah blah um and then he
eventually gets around to just saying no
just dictator day one in terms of what
I'll do on the border Etc um and people
hear that and they hear yeah this guy
still continues to be a threat to
democracy and you think to two days ago
when arthel Neville our own anchor had
to beam in to Trump's remarks when he
said I won the 202 20 election doesn't
stop with the lies about it and you can
say it's not the most important issue to
people but people have been voting on
preserving democracy and that's what Joe
Biden's talking about that he was the
guy who got Trump out and he's the guy
who can keep Trump out okay so I imagine
you would say the same about Stacy
Abrams who still is convinced that she
won the gubernatorial election but you
violent Insurrection let let me Stacy
Abrams will not concede and never
conceded that she lost the gubernatorial
election and then Second Time Around
really lost even bigger but look I hope
Joe sticks with the first answer I hope
he stays with the fact that you know
what I'm the one I'm in this to beat
Donald Trump because if he sticks with
that then it goes right to the to the
the guts of what's going on in this race
and it shows that Biden is more focused
on defeating Donald Trump and his
Department of Justice working with
Florida working with Washington making
sure that they've got all these
indictments they won't admit to the
meetings that have been had between
Justice Department officials and some of
the State uh prosecutors and it's all
about defeating him it's not about what
he's going to do for the American people
it's this jealousy it's this hatred it's
I'm the one who can beat him and the
saddest part of all this is when he's
being asked the question when he says
you know 50 people can beat him like who
and he just walks away it's such an
arrogance that he has such a
condescension that he has for the
pressent like I don't have to answer
that or you know I'm not getting any
money prove it you know there is
something that he's not a part of of the
the American people and who he wants us
to believe that he's one of us he's not
and the fact that they're not even using
biomics anymore is proof positive of
that he doesn't relate to the American
people maybe he did it one time or maybe
they were hoping that he would but 76%
of the American people believe the
country's headed in the wrong direction
Joe Biden is the one who's running the
country in the wrong wrong direction so
you know what I and the and the numbers
now Trump is ahead of Biden you know I
don't think Biden's going to be there in
uh to run as the candidate I really
don't that's it's not a it's a strange
message to tell the American people that
you need another four years there's a
lot of strange things going in here but
I want to uh respond to Jessica bringing
up 2020 remember that Joe claims he ran
against Trump based on a hoax that Trump
called Nazis fine people when he never
did that he was talking about fine
people on both sides of the statute
debate he was actually complimenting the
left who wanted to take down the statues
but the media covered up that hoax
because they're dirt bags who wanted to
call Trump an anti-semite even though he
has grandkids that are Jewish so it was
a huge lie and Jessica you're right it
worked think about how Joe won the
election find people hoax the Russian
hoax P tape the impeachment based on a
phone call that turned out to be pretty
damn accurate the cabal that suppressed
uh Joe Biden uh Hunter Biden's laptop
the idea that if you elected Trump that
would lead to war and then what happened
when Joe was elected two Wars two Wars
an imploded border inflation crime
everywhere and what was missing was what
Joe promised healing he was going to
heal us the first thing he did cleaved
the country in half demonized Trump
voters extreme Maga Republicans remember
that the biggest threat in our country
country domestic terrorists white
domestic terrorists parents who want to
speak up about their kids and then the
key phrase that Joe said in this uh
fundraiser we can't let him win we can't
let him win that's the bat signal all
right you see the Atlantic devoting an
entire issue to Trump is Hitler stories
Liz Cheney saying that Trump will end
democracy as she goes on her media tour
and we have the president saying we
can't let him win so the fix is in right
right it's an explicit approval that all
things all actions to stop orange Hitler
are permissible and again if you have
the threat of Hitler in front of you
everything's so it would be immoral if
you didn't do anything right think about
all the things you can do you know you
can lie you can cheat you can kill if
you think that's an exaggeration look at
their exaggerations right uh he will
cause World War III he will end
democracy about a president who couldn't
couldn't get Congress to build a wall
right this makes no sense and if you
think they won't stop at violence look
at what happened after 2016 in DC look
at the Summer of Love they're actually
telling us now what they're going to do
right we just watched two months of
justification of sexual atrocity we saw
an entire group of people think it's
okay what happened octo October 7
because it served a greater mission for
them so you know that's where I stand I
see where you stand thank you and in a
lovely stand is where you sit exactly in
that sweater from Easter I'm preparing
maybe yeah you working way up to that
ugly Christmas sweater all right up next
Democrats apparently think that standing
up for female athletes is transphobic
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else